[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit niki
siren schönen guten abend in allen
kristin otto das wird ein spannender
fußballabend gleich mehr dazu genannt
und wir blicken jetzt auf eine
weitreichende entscheidung heute im
parlament weil damit unser team
überblick beginnt
der bundestag stimmt mit großer mehrheit
für die lieferung schwerer waffen an die
ukraine
un-generalsekretär gute risch besucht
orte mutmaßlicher kriegsverbrechen und
forderte russland zur aufklärung auf
bundeskanzler scholz will sich mit g7
partner japan noch enger abstimmen bei
sanktionen genauso wie bei
wirtschaftlicher zusammenarbeit
energie und rohstoffe werden immer
teurer die inflation steigt im april auf
den höchsten stand seit über 40 jahren
noch vor gut zweieinhalb monaten niemals
für möglich gehalten heute fakt
deutschland wird der ukraine schwere
waffen liefern das beschloss der
bundestag mit großer mehrheit und
stimmen der union trotz klaren votums
kam klare und scharfe kritik von
unions-fraktionschef märz unter anderem
zum fernbleiben des kanzlers scholz ist
derzeit in japan über die entscheidung
und den schlagabtausch karl
hinterleitner
das geht heute morgen im bundestag um
die frage wie einig ist das parlament
beim beistand für die ukraine jede nur
mögliche hilfe zu leisten meint die
regierung sei moralische pflicht
dazu gehört finanzielle unterstützung
wirtschaftliche unterstützung
humanitäre unterstützung
und auch die unterstützung mit waffen
die liberale agnes strack zimmermann
fordert schon länger und vehement die
lieferung schwerer waffen die
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
meint jetzt steht die freiheit auf dem
spiel deshalb ruft deshalb schreibt die
ukraine nach unserer hilfe und das mag
manchen tierisch auf den keks gehen wir
sollten aber so lange bereit sein dazu
stehen so lange ist die vollständige
territoriale integrität der ukraine
wieder hergestellt die union kritisiert
dass olaf scholz nicht da ist und wirkt
die zögerlichkeit und führungsschwäche
vor der bundeskanzler hat über wochen
die diskussion über die frage ob der
ukraine denn nun waffen geliefert werden
sollten oder nicht hingehalten
offengelassen
ausweichend beantwortet das ist zögern
das ist zaubern und das ist
ängstlichkeit das sieht der kanzler an
dass er meldet sich von seiner
japanreise und begrüßt die entscheidung
im bundestag ich bin sehr dankbar für
die klare unterstützung die der deutsche
bundestag heute der politik der von mir
geführten regierung gegeben hat das
zeigt dass man in einer so
herausfordernden zeit eine politische
strategie verfolgen kann die viele dann
auch mittragen wollen die einzigen die
nicht wollen sind linke und afg die
linke ist grundsätzlich gegen
waffenlieferungen die afd man jetzt geld
ist verständnis auch für russland zu
haben es liegt im deutschen interesse
auch zukünftig zu beiden staaten ein
gutes verhältnis unterhalten politisch
wirtschaftlich und kulturell
am ende stimmte eine große mehrheit für
die lieferung schwerer waffen und panzer
aus deutschland in die ukraine eine
zeitenwende
russland verstärkt die drohungen
richtung westen der westen verstärkt
seine hilfe für die ukraine oder plant
es so will us-präsident beiden den
kongress um weitere 33 milliarden dollar
für kiew bitten die ukraine ermittelt
jetzt gegen zehn russische soldaten
wegen mutmaßlicher kriegsverbrechen im
käfer vor ort butscher unter anderem
dorthin reiste auch un-generalsekretär
gute risch und über das und mehr lena
sind abbruch der un-generalsekretär
scheint bewegt vom ausmaß der schäden
als er im zerstörten büro janka in der
nähe von kiew eintrifft krieg sei im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert eine
absurdität sagt er
ich stelle mir meine familie in einem
dieser häuser vor die jetzt zerstört und
schwarz sind ich sehe wie meine
enkelinnen in panik herumlaufen und wie
ein teil der familie schließlich getötet
wird
nach brot janker besucht er auch
butscher wo sich beweise für russische
kriegsverbrechen häufen angesichts der
eindrücke verlangt er eine gründliche
untersuchung und rechenschaft erst die
besucher in den trümmern später noch
einer bei präsident selensky
währenddessen im norden des landes steht
weiter unter beschuss bei
raketenangriffen sollen drei menschen
getötet worden sein
es ist nicht nur beängstigend es ist so
dass sich der magen verschmerzen
zusammenzieht und wenn es abend wird ist
es noch unheimlicher
das süd ukrainische person scheint fest
in pro russischer hand zu sein ab mai
soll hier sogar mit rubel gezahlt werden
einwohner demonstrieren gegen die
russischen besatzer die antworten mit
tränengas das bein dieses mannes soll
zudem von einer granate getroffen worden
seien
400 kilometer weiter östlich in mariupol
belegen neue satellitenbilder der us
firma messer das ausmaß der zerstörung
so sah die hafenstadt vor knapp einem
jahr aus und so vor drei tagen
um die ukrainischen streitkräfte zu
unterstützen bereitet die us armee
panzer träger vor soldaten verladen
artilleriegeschütze moskau warnt den
westen davor die ukraine mit schweren
waffen zu versorgen
der trend waffen in die ukraine zu
pumpen unter anderem schwere waffen
bedroht die sicherheit des kontinents
und provoziert instabilität
die ukraine erwidert sie werde sich auf
jede mögliche weise verteidigen
einschließlich attacken gegen lager und
stützpunkte russlands
mehr als fünf millionen menschen sind
inzwischen aus der ukraine geflüchtet
vor allem ins nachbarland polen und
jetzt fordert warschau finanzielle
hilfen von der europäischen union polen
beherberge zweieinhalb millionen
flüchtlinge und versorger verwundete
soldaten aus der ukraine sagte
ministerpräsident müller jetzt geht der
bild zeitung dafür habe die eu bisher
keinen cent gezahlt die eu kommission
widerspricht polen habe bereits mehr als
eine halbe milliarde euro für die
versorgung ukrainischer flüchtlinge
erhalten
jetzt zum antrittsbesuch des kanzlers in
japan vordergründig zur vorbereitung des
g 7 gipfels aber in kriegszeiten geht es
eben auch um das ausloten von
gemeinsamkeiten und neuen strategien und
weil wir eben in stark veränderten
zeiten leben auch immer um signale ein
besonders starkes war schon alleine das
olaf scholz tokio als erstes reiseziel
auf dem kontinent wählte rolle
es ist seine erste asienreise und sie
führt den bundeskanzler nicht nach china
sondern nach japan mit seiner neuen
asien strategie bricht scholz mit der
china nähe seiner vorgängerin merke
schon zu beginn macht dass der
bundeskanzler deutlich begrüßt auf
japanisch
es geht viel um die wehrhaftigkeit der
demokratien bei diesem besuch der krieg
in der ukraine verändert die
sicherheitspolitik beider länder auch
der japanische regierungschef key china
will mehr in rüstung investieren und
beide länder denken darüber nach
unabhängiger von chinas wirtschaft zu
werden klar ist unser unternehmen und
auch wir selber werden alles dafür tun
dass niemand abhängig ist von
lieferketten aus einem land jeweils dass
es die erfahrung die wir jetzt gemacht
haben mit der ukraine krise japan
schickt keine waffen in die ukraine weil
die pazifistische nachkriegsverfassung
dies nicht zulässt china verfolgt
deshalb die intensiven debatten in
deutschland aufmerksam
olaf sagte china sei trotz seines dicht
gepackten terminkalenders als
allererstes in asien nach japan gekommen
was zeige wie sehr deutschland japan als
partner schütze noch ist es nicht mehr
als ein antrittsbesuch doch schon der
zeigt am ende des ersten abends wiegen
nachhaltig der ukraine krieg
deutschlands handels und
außenbeziehungen verändern kann japan
ist dabei nur einer von vielen möglichen
verbündeten die deutschland brauchen
wird wenn es schluss machen möchte mit
einseitigen abhängigkeiten ein
antrittsbesuch im zeichen des russischen
angriffskrieges japan und deutschland
wollen enger zusammenrücken in einer
welt die immer mehr in zwei lager
zerfällt
wichtige nachricht für stromkunden ab
juli fällt die eeg-umlage komplett weg
so hat der bundestag entschieden eeg das
steht für erneuerbare energien gesetz
und damit wurde der verbraucher an den
kosten der energiewende beteiligt ob das
aus der umlage aber wirkliche entlastung
bringt es darf bezweifelt werden da die
preise für fossile energien wegen des
krieges jahr der zeit explodieren ja was
derzeit sehr vielen zu schaffen macht
und dann sorgen bereitet gibt es wieder
schwarz auf weiß die vorläufige
inflationsrate für den april und die
steigt weiter auf jetzt
7,4 prozent schauen wir wie sich das
zusammensetzt energie also strom heizen
tag
35 prozent mehr als im vorjahresmonat
oder lebensmittel plus achteinhalb
prozent vergleichsweise stabil blieben
die preise für dienstleistungen
plus 2,9 prozent mehr erfahren wir jetzt
von markus wolsiffer
ein döner für drei euro die zeiten sind
lange vorbei das beliebte fast food
kostet mancher arzt sechs euro und mehr
viele gastronomen müssen die hohen
kosten für energie und lebensmittel
weiter geben das trifft kleine und große
restaurants wenn wir jetzt von getreide
oder oder mail oder gemüse sprechen da
haben wir preissteigerungen von 25 bis
30 prozent bei rindfleisch eines unserer
wichtigsten rohstoffe natürlich sprechen
wir von 50 prozent preissteigerungen und
bei öl und molkereiprodukte sind es
sogar 60 bis 100 prozent
russlands krieg gegen die ukraine lässt
die energiepreise steigen und damit auch
die inflation im april liegt sie
vorläufig bei 7,4 prozent so hoch wie
seit über 40 jahren nicht mehr hinzu
kommt beide länder sind wichtige
getreideproduzenten auch deshalb steigen
die lebensmittelpreise
das problem die inflation trifft
einkommensschwächere in der regel
stärker weil sie einen größeren anteil
ihres geldes für güter des täglichen
bedarfs ausgeben einige verbände fordern
bereits die mehrwertsteuer für
grundnahrungsmittel abzuschaffen der
alltag wird immer teurer da ist
unglaublich viel preisdruck kostendruck
in der pipeline und das haben die
unternehmen noch lange nicht vollständig
weitergeleitet an die verbraucher so
dass die inflation in den kommenden
monaten sehr hoch bleiben wird für viele
verbraucher sind das keine guten
nachrichten
sie und ihr geld verlieren erneut an
kaufkraft während die angst vor einer
rezession weiter wächst
ja wie kann der deutsche staat die
inflation in den griff kriegen oder
brauchen wir eine europäische lösung
antworten auf solche fragen können sie
bei uns nachlesen in der zdf- heute- app
es ist jom ha schoah in israel
nationaler gedenktag für die sechs
millionen im holocaust ermordeten juden
am morgen heulten die sirenen
für zwei minuten standen die menschen
und das gesamte leben im land kurz still
an einer zeremonie im parlament nahm
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas als
ehrengast teil zuvor hatte sie bereits
in der gedenkstätte jad vaschem einen
kranz niedergelegt
gedenken und erinnern auch in auschwitz
mehr als 2000 zumeist junge jüdinnen und
juden aus vielen ländern nahmen am
marsch der lebenden teil von auschwitz
nach birkenau dem größten der deutschen
vernichtungslager in der ns-zeit tom
pollock berichtet
zwei generationen gegen das vergessen
etwa gosberg hat das grauen von
auschwitz überlebt seine enkelin will so
etwas nie wieder zu lassen menschen aus
25 ländern sind zum ersten mal sch der
lebenden seit 2009 10 gekommen nur noch
acht überlebende laufen den weg vom
konzentrationslager auschwitz zum
vernichtungslager birkenau auch eve
kugler die in halle an der saale geboren
wurde wir versuchten nach israel zu
kommen aber haben es nicht geschafft es
war nicht gut mein vater kam nach
buchenwald wir haben ihn daraus bekommen
und sind vor dem krieg nach frankreich
geflohen
neben jüdischen gruppen sind dieses jahr
auch ukrainische flüchtlinge dabei die
an diesem ort ein zeichen setzen wollen
wir nehmen hier teil dass das was
passiert ist im bewusstsein bleiben wir
sollten immer daran denken dass
menschliches leben unbezahlbar ist
[Musik]
wir wollen nicht dass sich das
wiederholt wir wollen nicht dass das
unsere nation passiert
trotz aller anteilnahme gibt es auch
mahnende stimmen den holocaust mit mehr
als sechs millionen ermordeten juden
nicht gleichzusetzen mit den ereignissen
in der ukraine
wir vermischen nicht den holocaust mit
den gräueltaten in diesem krieg aber
gleichzeitig wollen wir betonen dass für
jegliche form des bösen antisemitismus
und rassismus zerstören müssen
und so sind sie heute vereint in schmerz
mit der erinnerung an die vergangenheit
und dem erlebten die gegenwart
[Musik]
eindrucksvolles gedenken wir machen
jetzt einen schnitt und kommen zu corona
die sieben tage inzidenz ist laut robert
koch institut weiter gesunken auf
826 allerdings gehen experten seit
einiger zeit davon aus dass viele fälle
gar nicht erfasst werden auch weil nicht
mehr alle infizierten einen pcr test
machen lassen das lka registrierte
binnen eines tages
130.000 104 neuinfektionen das sind 56
1221 weniger als vor einer woche
innerhalb eines tages wurden
246 todesfälle erfasst
ehrenamtlich helfen das ist eine
lebenseinstellung und bleibt hoch im
kurs das ist das ergebnis des ehrenamts
monitors der im auftrag des malteser
hilfsdienstes erstellt wurde
35 prozent der befragten erklärten
allerdings sie wollten sich lieber
spontan zur mithilfe entscheiden als
sich langfristig an eine organisation zu
binden roman les kuba hat helfern hat
helfer in berlin getroffen
silke sabi los ist eine von vielen
ehrenamtlichen helfern rund um das
ankunft zelt am berliner hauptbahnhof
die chemikerin spricht russisch
unterstützt die ukrainischen flüchtlinge
bei offenen fragen ihr erstes ehrenamt
empfindet sie nur positiv
die jedem einzelnen die man anspricht
und an lächelt und der nette herr drückt
und der 1 mit tränen in den augen umarmt
das ist wirklich was über kriegt ja auch
was zurück die malteser haben nach
ausbruch des krieges die deutschen nach
ihrer hilfsbereitschaft gefragt demnach
gaben 27 prozent bereits geld gespendet
17 prozent andere hilfsgüter 5%
sammelten oder transportierten
hilfsgüter 4% halfen in
gemeinschaftsunterkünften
auch bei den maltesern ist das ehrenamt
immens wichtig
52.000 freiwillige unterstützen
bundesweit auch die ukrainischen
flüchtlinge wie hier am berliner
busbahnhof die krisen werden zunehmen
prophezeit die hilfsorganisationen umso
mehr wachse die bedeutung des
ehrenamtlichen engagement
gerade in dieser ukraine krise aber auch
in anderen krisen im vorfeld haben wir
gesehen wie hilfsbereit die menschen in
unserem land sind das ist einfach
großartig aber wir stellen auch fest
dass sie nicht mehr so verbindlich sich
langfristig engagieren wollen und das
ist für uns eine eine herausforderung
auch silke sabi los möchte sich ungern
längerfristig binden obwohl sie sicher
ist dass sie auch nach dem engagement
ankunftszeit weiter ehrenamtlich
arbeiten wird
wir sind jetzt beim sport und wir sind
bei der europa league zwei deutsche sind
noch dabei neben leipzig frank wurden
und das passspiel ist der unvergessliche
stichwort magische nacht ja ganz so
viele eintracht fans wie zuletzt beim
überragenden auftritt in barcelona
werden es in englands hauptstadt nicht
sein gleichwohl fiebert die frankfurter
äußerst selbstbewusst dem halbfinal
hinspiel in london beim west ham united
entgegen
london am nachmittag die eintracht-fans
stimmen sich schon mal ein auf das spiel
am abend wohl dem der eines von 3000
gäste tickets erhalten hat denn laut
eintracht-trainer glasner wird es ein
heißes duell gegen west ham heißt es
über den schmerz zu gehen jetzt geht es
darum in den finale der europa league
einzuziehen und
deswegen aus für mich persönlich ist es
das größte bisher und ich hoffe dass wir
noch ein größeres folgt
1976 beim letzten aufeinandertreffen im
europapokal der pokalsieger gewann west
ham mit dem sieg in barcelona im rücken
reist die eintracht nicht nur mit
breiter brust nach london geht es nach
den plänen soll auch das olympiastadion
zum hexenkessel werden mit offiziell
3000 eintracht anhängern
und in der champions league bleibt der
fc liverpool auf kurs richtung dritten
triumph nach 2005 und 2009 10 das team
von jürgen klopp der seinen vertrag bei
den reds vorzeitig bis 2026 verlängert
hat verschafft er sich im hinspiel gegen
den fc villarreal eine gute
ausgangsposition nach vielen knapp
verpassten gelegenheiten verwertet
liverpool kurz nach der pause eine
chance die gar keine ist hendersons
flanke abgefälscht das längst fällige 1
0 nur zwei minuten später dann aber auch
ein wunderbar herausgespieltes tor manet
nach pass von salat zum 2 0-endstand das
fazit ihres trainers kurz und knapp
jungs haben sehr gute erst seite
gespielt ohne zu treffen und eine sehr
gute zweite methode so soweit sogut mehr
gibt es auch nichts zu sagen
klopp auf den punkt alle stimmen und
tore der beiden halbfinalspiele in der
champions league können sie ausführlich
wie gewohnt bei uns online sehen auf zdf
heute und in der zdf- heute- app also
reinschauen dass du uns nicht wirklich
dankeschön christin und wir haben zum
ende der sendung noch ein ganz
speziellen rückblick und zwar auf die
korona zeit da geht es um babys im
corona jahr 20 21 hat nämlich einen
kleinen baby boom gegeben über die
gründe darf sich dann jeder selber
gedanken machen
795.000 zukünftige heute zuschauer kamen
zur welt + 2 notiz am rande
erwartet wurde weniger groß feiern war
natürlich auch schwierig wird vielleicht
nachgeholt aber gute nachrichten bei 11
bis 21 grad morgen für die meisten
freundliches frühlingswetter details
gleich von katja horneffer ich empfehle
wie immer wärmstens das heute journal um
21.45 mit christian sievers und uns wird
es freuen wenn sie morgen um 7 wieder
dabei sind schönen dunk und noch einen
entspannten abend
[Musik]
gelernt heute gab es viel sonne einige
quellwolken hier im osten und küsten
nebel der sich im laufe des tages an der
ostsee aber auflöste gut zu erkennen
sind auch die hohen wolkenfeldern über
großbritannien und frankreich und wie
die sich über die tieferen wolken hier
über der nordsee schieben diese
niedrigeren wolken die haben sich auch
aufgelöst die hohen wolkenfelder aber
die ziehen im laufe der nacht weiter zu
uns rein häufig aber es ist klar es
benutze ich auch mal etwas nebel und hin
und wieder droht durchaus noch einmal
bodenfrost bei tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen plus zwei und minus ein grad
milder bleibt die nacht an der ost- und
an der nordseeküste in der mitte und im
südwesten bei 7 bis 4 grad und morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen zwischen
11 grad an der nordsee und 21 grad am
oberrhein am vormittag gibt es noch viel
sonnenschein hier in süddeutschland und
auch in sachsen sonst sind schon einige
hohe wolkenfelder unterwegs kann sich
auch wieder küsten nebel bilden und im
laufe des nachmittags ziehen diese
wolkenfelder weiter nach südosten dann
könnte die sonne hier im nordwesten
wahrscheinlich sogar hinter
wolkenfeldern verschwinden bei einem
leichten wind aus nordwestlichen
richtungen in den nächsten tagen geht es
mit freundlichem frühlingswetter weiter
es wird allerdings von südwesten
unbeständiger und dann drohen auch
gewitter bei 12 bis 20 grad guten abend